[Musique]
on
mes chers concitoyens c'est maintenant
c'est maintenant qu'il faut nous
rassembler c'est maintenant qu'il
faudrait c'est la france c'est
maintenant qu'il faut retrouver
confiance en nous et reprendre notre
destin
c'est maintenant qu'il faut maîtriser la
finance la remettre au service de
l'économie donnait sa valeur au travail
au mérite et à l'effort c'est maintenant
qu'il faut une république exemplaire
c'est maintenant qu'il faut combattre la
corruption mettre fin au favoritisme
lutter contre les rémunérations
indécentes
c'est maintenant qu'il faut et de nos
entreprises soutenir notre industrie
défendre notre agriculture protéger
notre environnement et encourager des
énergies nouvelles
c'est maintenant qu'il faut retrouver le
sens de ce qui est juste du partage
équitable de l'effort
c'est maintenant qu'il faut mettre fin
aux privilèges et c'est maintenant qu'il
faut rire priorité à l'école maintenant
se garantir à tous la sécurité l'accès à
la santé au logement
il faut donner à crantée l'euro la
culture et la recherche
c'est maintenant qu'il faut se tourner à
nouveau vers l'avenir et redonner à la
jeunesse toutes ses chances c'est
maintenant qu'ils pourront créer de la
solidarité entre les générations
si maintenant qu'il faut refuser une
france divisée dire non à ceux qui
appellent à la peur on lève ni peur du
reste du monde peur de l'autre
c'est maintenant que nous avons le plus
besoin de ce qui fait notre cohésion
entre force et notre fierté
la république
c'est maintenant qu'il faut nous
rassembler pour réussir le changement
mes chers concitoyens
le changement c'est maintenant
[Musique]